uh peyton manning is making cold calls
to indie liquor stores to put us bourbon
on shelves if you can go a little lower
to read this
peyton manning is not uh too uh
enshrined in a hall of fame or too
caught up in the overwhelmingly rave
reviews of the monday night football
mega cast which they're crushing is
incredible yeah to admit what his most
critical job has been of late he's been
a hustler his words not ours in a world
of liquor hustling is key manning said
or he as he actually said you kind of
have to hustle on it or it gets lost in
the shuffle what manning has been
hustling is a bourbon brand called
sweden cove tennessee bourbon for the
liquor con
uh uh connoisseur say that say the word
connoisseur connoisseur
out there 84 percent corn uh eight
percent right eight percent mark malted
barley someone's gonna come to
indianapolis i'm in the cold calling
business manning told indystar yes
manning has been picking up the phones
and making the calls the call that might
must certainly seem like a prank to the
person on the other end you can imagine
the pitch can you imagine you get a call
from this guy i'm peyton manning what do
i need to do to get my bourbon into your
liquor store what's his closing
percentage
are you kidding me knowing this guy he
probably has a ratio he probably got
data for everything i'm shooting you
know what's what's high school it's
completion percentage for his career or
his closing percentage what do you think
he was closing oh i want to say closing
how do you say no to it if you believe
it's him right because i would if it was
me i'd be like yeah right man you know
what i i would facetime i'd say here let
me just face something if then you don't
believe me let me face that he facetimed
you and then it's one hundred percent
100 yeah but but are you surprised
though see these are the small little
you know like i bet you got stories like
even you talked about it earlier what
you were doing when you're sending your
stuff when you're writing the stories
behind every great entrepreneur or great
hustler you have weird stories like this
that doesn't make sense i'll give you a
crazy story okay i haven't told this
story for like eight years seven years
so it's 2000 let me see what year it is
it's 2007.
i'm about to qualify for a trip to go to
dubrovnik to go to venice to go to
masanovia to go to italy to go to all
those places okay
my assistant at the time i asked him did
you renew my life insurance license okay
he says i renewed all your license i
said are you positive he says i renewed
all your licenses when i ever missed it
i said you know what this guy's a pretty
credible guy he's been with me for many
years fine you renewed it i renewed it
fantastic so i go one day goes by two
day goes by the last week all the
business that goes in i'm going to
europe
all of a sudden i get a call from the
company saying yeah none of the stuff
you're submitting right now it's going
to count for you why because your
license has been suspended for two weeks
i said what
he says because you forgot to renew your
license so what do i do i scream his
name
put him on speaker ma'am can you please
tell him what you just told me right now
yeah your license hasn't been renewed
because it wasn't done so his face turns
red he's panicked and he's freaking out
i said what the hell is going on here
with my license being renewed i want to
go to dubrovnik i want to go to all
these places there's no way this is
going to happen i'm telling you i renew
the show to me
hour later he says i f doubt i didn't
renew it
i've lost my mind at this point okay oh
i'm losing my mind so okay let me see
what i can do i call the department of
insurance california and by the way
department insurance california
most difficult people to work with so i
call and i say yes uh my name is patrick
david how are you man i speak with the
manager please this is her great hey my
license i just got word that expired
what do i need to do to renew my license
they said sir it's going to take about
four to six weeks to renew i said no no
you don't understand four to six weeks
is fifty thousand dollars of commission
sixty thousand of i need this thing to
be renewed sir everybody calls us for
this this happens all the time it's okay
just be patient with us four to six
weeks we'll renew it her name was gail i
said gail i'm on the phone like five six
seven i said kale gail let me just put
it to you this way
if you don't renew my license i swear to
god i'm gonna be there tomorrow morning
i will dance outside your office
i will bring flowers i will bring 200
people singing your name non-stop until
you renew my license
i'm gonna show up tomorrow morning got
five images patrick even if you show we
cannot renew it i said i'm gonna make
the biggest scene until you renew my
license patrick don't waste your money
as i'm coming don't don't don't come
please don't i said gail i'm coming to
california what happens i tell my guy
book the flight
i go to sacramento i go find a
department of insurance i flew to
sacramento now watch what happens there
is no door like there is not a door it's
one of those doors you know the doors
behind like an industrial building
like there is not a window to see who's
working inside but i'm there at 5am i
tell my hotel guy bring me two buckets
of coffee okay for me from starbucks
bring me dozens of donuts i'm going to
stand out there keep telling i'm giving
everybody a flyer can you please give
this to gail i'm patrick coffee to
everybody everybody's coming in hi how
are you i'm patrick bediva i need to
renew my license could you please tell
gail here's my flight i'm giving it to
everybody one by one by one they're
going in they're going it they're going
it
and then an hour later she doesn't show
up two hours later she doesn't show up
one employee comes out patrick we can't
we're not gonna renew your license for
four to six weeks do you realize if we
do this everybody else is gonna do what
you're doing we cannot do this i said
you gotta renew my license i said if you
don't i have uh mariachi folks showing
up right now i have dancers showing up
right now she says you can't do this
kind of stuff this is too much i said
i'm gonna do all this stuff anyways
long story short gail comes out okay
kel comes and says patrick what do i
need to do to get rid of you everybody's
talking about you right now sigil just
renew my license
says if i renew your license will you
leave town i said i'm not leaving until
on your website it says patrick by
david's license renewed to the date okay
she says let me see what i can do she
goes inside amor calls me my chief
compliance officer says patrick your
license has been you know you've been
terminated they're calling me from what
are we going to do you can't go to
europe i said dude let me just say i'm
in california right now in sacramento
let me see what i can do
gail comes out she says here your
license is renewed i said gil give me
the biggest hug gave her a hug got her
two dozen roses she says get the hell
out of here and said don't ever tell
anybody so i'm not telling anybody i'm
just telling two people right now like a
handful of us right now anyways tomorrow
morning
your license was freaking renewed they
made a mistake i said nobody made the
mistake i'm in sacramento anyways so
those are the stories that many times
people don't i went to europe cost you
10 grand to get your license my favorite
trip of all time up until that point was
dubrovnik till today my favorite place
in the world
if i didn't renew my license i'm not
going to do bro sweet
that's that's the story sometimes behind
closed doors you don't hear about so
manning massive massive shout out it's
like a hustler like manning it's the
competitive spirit and it's what you
talked about with you before you had
that addictive personality but you
channeled it into the right way now uh a
buddy of mine i talk i talked to you
about prince lorenzo borghese this this
guy was on the bachelor he's been on
bachelor in paradise
bro yeah first of all name like that you
go up to a girl what's your name mary
what's your name prince what's that
lorenzo borges lorenzo yeah it's a done
deal he was in uh what was that
celebrity big brother with the you got
into the fight the situation he's a good
friend of my buddy rocco they were rocco
was on lucky bastards on esquire with
them they they know each other anyway
the point is this guy's got notoriety
fame money he sells uh south beach
brewery and now he's driving around the
truck himself delivering the stuff
himself going and making the sales calls
himself because he's like hey i put my
thing into this i'm not going to call
people i'm not going to tell people i'm
not he doesn't want to be like cabo wabo
this is so and so he shake my hand this
is mine like it's actually mine i'm
doing it and it's really really
important to him he like he likes that
he likes to hunt he likes being out
there in it that's what makes the story
sexy that's what makes the story
exciting you have to have that story of
a hustle whenever you're doing something
big i just want to know where he gets
the time to do it
peyton manning dude at that point the
bigger you get the more support you got
you have no idea you have so much
support biggest thing people
misunderstand about business
is there's a 10-year period of you not
having a life there's 10 years and
that's the 10 years people don't want to
give up but you have no life when i tell
you no life i mean you have no life it's
an 80 hour week of no life
then after that tenure
the amount of support and help you have
your life is given back to you and you
gain back years for that 10 years of
sacrifice you made that's the exchange
people don't want to make that's what
exactly what happened yeah i mean i
don't i really don't do anything i don't
want to do anymore but you earned it
though
right yeah yeah literally if there's
something in my life that i really don't
want to do then i have somebody to
support person that's able to do it for
me like eduardo over there you know so
uh for instance if you don't want to
support arnold classic you just don't
support it yeah that's true that's right
yeah but giving that the work gives you
the ability to have freedoms you know
that's what i think of when people talk
about like making it and you know making
being financially free to me it's just
being able to do or not do the things
you want to do so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]